thank you like seriously such a fan you
know this by the way when you get here
she is he she wrote me a handwritten
note I mean you're so sweet when did you
have time to do that oh I write
handwritten letters for every guest on
my show yeah yeah well it's important I
know what it is to make the rounds you
such a fan hey and I'm also a super fan
and you know this because she came to
our set in like five thousand eleven or
twelve I don't remember that I have no
memory we were talking about that
earlier
um I do know that in 2012 we were tater
tots for sure it was it was awesome to
this show so great yeah I know it has
20/20
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
but I mean you know any boy at that time
completely had a crush on you guys like
peanut butter
where's my cane did you guys ever get
into the vampire stuff y'all over to the
vampire crap life was actually your life
yeah what's in it was in Twilight my
daughter Jameson's Twilight obsessed so
yes I read all the books before even the
first movie came I loved anything kind
of fantasy or I mean because sometimes
life can be so good but you're like I
want to scape ISM and you know it's so
wet well thank you yes I loved visiting
else so the guy that played my brother
on this very long-running TV show we
love each other we have wanted to kill
each other about 800 times that means
brothers but that means brothers and we
have now not only were we on a
television show for eight years together
but now we've started a company together
and it's really special the Salvatore
boys Salvatore brothers have a bourbon
and it's going to be a lot what's the
name renouncing the name you know yeah
not yet okay so it should I mean you're
now with V Wars you're the executive
producer director and you're starring in
in viewers right yes yes
kinda looks it's about like kind of
vapors but not really it's like kind of
difference like disease almost takes
over right it's the only it's the only
vampire show you've ever seen that's
actually ever been that is not
supernatural it's science-based this is
about a disease a pathogen that's found
a virus that's found because of melting
glaciers yeah things are starting to be
exposed that are very harmful to
humanity and livestock and Wildlife and
stuff so these are things that it's not
even possible it's probable that they're
gonna be things that come out and get
into everybody gets in this battle about
if humans caused it or whatever who
cares what caused it it happened to up
at me but let's figure it out but do you
ever get mistaken for Rob Lowe awesome
he is he he was so sweet he walked up to
my wife he walked up to Nikki Reed at a
I think was a Golden Globes party or
something and he walked up to her and
she'd never met him and she walked up he
walked up to her and he grabbed her face
and he just said this is what you're
gonna be looking at in 15 years but any
woman that is that close to Rob Lowe is
sort of like and it was very sweet
really sweet man no but I think that's
really cool that it people might seem
that V Wars is far-fetched but I do love
that it's based in science and a lot of
like things actually happening in but
also attacks it also attacks a lot of
the big tentpole things that we're
dealing with right now in society we
want to have this this feel of the genre
enough like a walking dead but the
social relevance of like a Handmaid's
Tale I mean these are shows that really
have affected people
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this